[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates
Americans still held hostage where is
journalist Austin Tice last seen alive
in Syria where his former FBI agent
Robert Levinson last seen alive in Iran
and please help me at home now the
mother of journalist James Foley
beheaded by Isis five years ago this
summer speaks out asking whether the US
government is doing enough to help bring
back its kidnapped citizens the
conditions here along the border are
getting worse
an American shame immigrant children
held in deplorable conditions no soap no
toothbrushes you know if you don't have
a toothbrush if you don't have soap if
you don't have a blanket it's not safe
and sanitary well wouldn't everybody
agree to that one doctor calls it a
place of torture while for-profit prison
companies make big money
author John Carlos pray on America's
stealth war at the border and who's
getting rich because of them plus our
shouta
it wasn't until a reporter from New York
showed up to tell their story that a
federal judge became aware of the racial
disparity at two louisiana high schools
if you are teaching you know what you're
doing how you expect me to do now top
school officials have lost their jobs
and change is on its way from the law on
crime network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates good evening and welcome
tonight Americans taken hostage many
still missing it was five years ago this
summer that Isis began to execute a
series of young Americans who had been
taken hostage journalists and aid
workers who have gone to Syria their
plight revealed the frustration and
anger of the American hostage families
who accused the FBI and the White House
under the Obama administration of not
doing enough to help and in fact often
blocking efforts the families were
making to get their loved ones freedom
the first of the Americans to be
executed by Isis was photo journalist
James Foley and since then his parents
have been outspoken in their criticism
of how they were treated by the US
government
the squeek Foley
parents who have created the James Foley
Legacy Foundation are out with a new
report on us hostage policy and we're
joined tonight by Diane Foley to talk
about all this Diane thank you so much
for joining us you went through such
frustration from the government is it
any better now yes we're very happy to
report that things are better for
Americans who are considered hostage
that is Americans who are held by
terrorists criminal gangs or pirates 50
well we also found out that Americans
who are unlawfully detained by foreign
governments on the other hand are sorely
in need of similar similar interagency
effort to bring them home that was
meaning people like Robert but that like
in Saudi Arabia visit dr. wily the tight
Venezuela for May but now in Iran
Princeton graduate student way so there
are hundreds of unlawfully detained
American by foreign government or are in
need of a similar interagency effort and
support by the highest levels of
government and I am as you know and as
you said a number of Americans taken
hostage over the last few years remain
among the missing journalists Austin
Tice taken in Syria and as you said
former FBI agent Robert Levinson last
seen in Iran who issued this chilling
plea to the US government on video
please help me 33 years of service to
the United States something Diane Foley
just how many Americans are there who
remain hostages overseas you know the
actual numbers are classified and we are
trying to get more accurate numbers but
we definitely estimate hundreds of
Americans are taken
and or unlawfully detained every year
abroad you say hundreds of them really
hundreds hundreds Brian many many we are
on top reported because often they feel
the best way to get people home is keep
the case very quiet but at times that
benefit captures and doesn't get the
attention of the highest levels of our
cup and Diane on that point a question
for you from our control room from
executive producer Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda Dianne hostage families are often
told to keep quiet not to tell the
public not to tell anyone what's going
on what's your thoughts on that having
been through all this every situation is
very unique and it really depends on the
family because it is true that a lot of
media coverage can increase the value of
so one has to take that into account it
also can help find the person and find
people who might be able to help them
come home so it's a very personal choice
and often depends on the strategy of how
they are going to be brought home Diane
are you left feeling that if the
government had done more your son could
have been brought home oh definitely
Brian I feel we did not engage as a
government because of the civil war in
Syria and therefore we missed out on a
lot of intelligence about Isis that we
would have known and had we engaged with
the captors of the four Americans so I
do feel they could have turned out
differently if our government had
dissociated with them the standard US
policy is that Americans don't pay
ransom to get hostages released from
terrorists that was the case they told
you in fact they actually threatened you
with prosecution if you tried
the raise of money on your own is that
policy you think correct well there is
no actual research that shows that not
paying ransom brings people home it's
actually the opposite Americans and the
British because of that policy have
worse outcomes however I feel there's
many ways to negotiate ransoms only one
there are sanctions there are other
things that captors want
I think the key issue is the need to
engage with captors when our citizens
are at risk and finally let me ask you
how do you rate what grade do you give
to the Trump administration on this
issue I have to commend the Trump
administration the Trump administration
has made the return of Americans more of
a priority without a doubt and as a
matter of fact I'm hoping as Secretary
Pompeo and the president vote the e20
they will remember these innocent
Americans such as dr. walid Baha'i
Princeton graduate student Wang the
Venezuelan executives who are held
hostage there as well as in Syria much
Kamala's is that's just the tip of the
iceberg there are so many other
Americans and in need of US leadership
and absolutely Diane Foley thank you so
much for joining us thank you next the
American shame the treatment of
immigrant children at the border one
doctor called it a torture Center when
we return
you
you
we're back now with a hard look at what
is an American disgrace the treatment of
immigrant children at the border this
week officials moved hundreds of
children out of one of the worst
detention facilities after reports of
deplorable conditions at a contentious
court hearing judges took a government
larger task for the conditions there
it's within everybody's common
understanding that you know if you don't
have a toothbrush if you don't have soap
if you don't have a blanket it's not
safe and sanitary well wouldn't
everybody agree to that do you agree to
that well I think it's I think those are
there's fair reason to find that those
things may be part of see maybe are a
part what do you say maybe we're joint
and I'm a one of the few reporters who's
been on the front line since the
beginning John Carlos Frey John thanks
for joining us your new book on the
subject sand and blood is just out what
do you make of what's going on with the
children at the border I have report
after report after report of children
being mistreated by Customs and Border
Protection over the past couple of
decades you and I have even reported
together about things that happen on the
border I'm actually glad that this is
coming to the forefront but this is
actually US policy we're supposed to
make this journey and incarceration
about as bad as you can possibly imagine
this is this is part of what Donald
Trump is basically using legally in
other words to make it to discourage
families from making the move towards
the u.s. is that the idea make it so
painful yes the policy is known as a
deterrence policy we're never going to
be able to keep everybody from coming
we're never gonna be able to seal off
the border and keep migrants from coming
so let's shake them up a little bit
let's make them cross the deserts or the
mountains if we catch them and we
incarcerate them let's not give them a
cushy bed let's not give them good food
let's not even let them sleep let's
leave the lights on no toothpaste no
toothbrush no no mattresses the way the
children are being treated is part of US
government policy I think this has all
come to a head this week with some of
those moving pictures of chilled
and the young father who died along with
his daughter drowned trying to cross the
Rio Grande
do you see opportunity for change here
now because of a national outrage it
seems like that's the only thing that
ever moves the needle if if the
citizenry is aware of what's going on
this is policy that has gone on under
under a cloak of secrecy for for a long
time so I'm hopeful that the the fact
that this now is in the light and keep
exactly what happens that maybe at least
the administration made you your new
book deals with the people who are
actually making money from all this how
can that be well you know we just saw an
appropriations bill that the House
passed and it looks like the Senate
passed as well for four point plus
billion dollars for aid who's going to
implement that aid those are defense
contractors that's four billion dollars
for the most part put into private
enterprises hands to feed the children
to to provide sanitary conditions this
is all a system of private contractors
that basically manage the border and
manage the way people are detained we
detain about 50,000 people in detention
facilities and 75% of those detention
facilities are privately run and
privately managed so their discomfort
means big money for someone it's
estimated that we've when we've started
to see children at the border at the
beginning of last year that defense
contractor swooped in and made about a
billion dollars instituting these these
places where they're being held 1
billion dollars to hold children John
some of your reporting that's been on
this program has to deal with the fact
that that area of Central America from
which many of the people are coming is
suffering from a famine with conditions
that are really responsible that are
drying up the land sort of climate
change we're seeing some of the early
results the World Food Program which is
a subsidiary of the United Nations in
February this year has declared 2.1
million people as being food insecure
that is the step before all-out famine
and that's as you say is a direct result
of people losing their crops the is
drying out due to climate me there
throughout
now it took quite 1 million people who
can't feed themselves we're starting to
seat them at the border and you think
that's driving them towards the u.s. the
fact that they can't feed themselves
they don't have jobs well this is one of
the sending factors by Gration is
complicated if you can't feed your
family if you can't find a job if you're
afraid for your life because of the
violence all of those things piled on
may make someone make the decision to
move northward and that's what we're
seeing I was in the caravans at the end
of last year that we're heading to the
us-mexico border and many of the people
that I spoke to were farmers who could
no longer farmed land because the rains
just weren't coming and I talked to
several people who were living on one
tortilla a day that's about as much as
they could muster president Trump has
repeatedly said this is the
responsibility and the fault frankly of
the Obama administration is there
anything to that I don't I don't even
understand what that statement means
he's been president for two years the
executive branch is responsible for
implementing immigration policy
I think Obama's been out of office for a
while so either he's not taking
responsibility or trying to find blame
but it's his job now if Obama screwed
things up that was a couple of years ago
it's his job now his administration is
responsible for what we're seeing help
our viewers understand the whole issue
of asylum us grants asylum were being
flooded the people seeking asylum we
have laws on the books that actually
allow people to come to the border and
say I am being persecuted I'm a victim
of violence I am afraid for my life
I'd like to come and seek refuge in the
United States we let them in and we
allow them to go through a court process
it's the courts who decide whether or
not their claims are legitimate and if
the court decides that they're not they
will be deported 90% of the cases are
usually not found to be credible so most
of the people are returned but they are
given the opportunity to make their
claim so the fact that the president is
keeping people from making a claim of
asylum is basically in violation of our
own laws the the picture that we're all
seeing this horrible picture of the man
with his child drown in the Rio Grande
is is said by his wife to
have tried to make a claim of asylum but
he was denied so he tried to swim the
river so I think that there is blood on
the hands of the administration by not
allowing these individuals to make the
legal claims and in some cases that's
why they're coming to the border blood
on their hands you really mean that yeah
I really do you know I mean if we're not
giving Children and Families the
opportunity to make a claim of asylum
which we by law are supposed to and
people are dying as a result who's
responsible if migrants are dying by the
thousands in the deserts due to our
policies are we not responsible the only
the only individuals are the only group
who can alleviate the suffering is the
federal government and if they're not
doing that I think that we have to take
a look at the fact that our policies are
causing great harm yeah I I'm not really
being hyperbolic here and as a
journalist I'm very careful about the
words that I choose but I'm not sure
that people would be dying in mass as
they are or being treated in such
inhumane conditions if it wasn't for the
way we're implementing policy John
Carlos Frey thank you so much for
joining us as always thank you Brian up
next our shout out to the reporter who
got the attention of a federal judge to
deal with the racial disparity between
two high schools in the same County in
Louisiana when we return
you
you
our shout out tonight is an update on
the great work done by a New York
reporter who helped give voice to some
high school students in Louisiana who
wanted to know why the predominantly
white high school in the same County had
so much better facilities than that
their school it got the attention of the
federal judge overseeing the district
who had no idea what was going on until
he saw the report the mold the carpet
the walls itself the classrooms the
teachers everything that you need in the
school or could use in the school he's
not there
reporter Dan Lieberman of the online
media outlet now this went to Quetta
hula parish in Louisiana two block high
school where most of the students are
African American to see why students are
speaking out in what conditions and deep
south schools are like more than six
decades after desegregation we saw a
local news piece from rural Louisiana
about these kids were protesting
conditions at their high school i talked
with lieberman at the novice studios in
new york where the kids afraid to speak
out where they afraid they might be
punished by the school they were
surprised to see that that someone from
out of town out of state was showing up
to really put a spotlight on these
issues they weren't sure it was going to
make much of a difference because they
they really felt like in this parish in
this state their their voices didn't
matter and they weren't going to get a
change what made the story so powerful
is what Lieberman then discovered nearby
but 13 miles away there's another school
in the same school district that looks a
lot different nearly 90 percent of the
senior class here is white they perform
better academically and enroll in
college at a higher rate it really did
feel wrong it felt like an injustice
this is one School District the schools
should not look that different and that
you know there's been desegregation
orders in place since the 1960s and for
you know if you're in eleventh and
twelfth grade at one school
majority-white other school majority
black you look at the conditions of the
two high schools and and you see that
the funding doesn't add up
so we just tried to film inside
Harrisonburg high school but the
superintendent won't let our cameras
inside they don't want the principal's
to talk to us on camera but there's a
clear notable difference in how the
school looks compared to black high
school but Lieberman was able to get the
superintendent on camera when we talked
to students and we talked to families at
black high school they compared it to
Harrisonburg they say Harrisonburg has
beautiful facilities why do you think
they're saying there's such a difference
several of the other schools communities
of passed Bondi she's specifically
around facility renovation and
refurbishment and in the recent years
Johnsville hasn't passed any such issue
to address their schools both high
schools are in the same district and
Lieberman says he thinks there's more to
it than bond issues after talking to one
school board member so I asked the
school board member why don't you just
consolidate the schools and she said the
parents at that school they don't want
their kids going to school with those
kids because of their moral character
that's what she said yeah when it was
what a big load for was it suppose it's
a code for racism it's it and it it was
so it was so obvious you feel it there
and it was wrong Lee Berman's report had
immediate impact federal judge Dedra
overseeing the long delayed
desegregation efforts in that school
district saw the now this report and
ordered a hearing into what's going on
so essentially he was unaware of this
disparity until your report that's right
so he gave you full credit for bringing
this to
tenshun neither the school board nor the
Justice Department had done that he said
I'm he said that I'm so glad you came
down
Louisiana why do you think it took an
outsider to go down there and to reveal
this to me I really think that it speaks
to the broader crisis in journalism
where areas like this in the deep south
in rural areas they're not getting asked
tough questions reporters are not
showing up they're asking tough
questions since that original report Dan
Lieberman tells us the high school
principal and the superintendent are
both out of jobs one resigned the other
retired and now the federal judge
overseen the long-delayed desegregation
efforts has ordered school officials to
report back to him every other month
about what's being done to correct this
glaring black/white discrepancy good
work Dan well that's our program for
tonight thanks so much for joining us
we'll see you back here next week good
night
Daniel Vegas not guilty I'm Erin Keller
join me for the daily debrief it's your
chance to catch the hottest moments of
the biggest cases we cover here on the
law and crime Network plus the day's top
legal stories coast to coast if you
missed anything during our live trial
coverage we bring it to you again on The
Daily debris it's your chance to get
caught up in your favorite cases Monday
through Friday live from 5:00 to 5:30
right here on lawn crime tonight on The
Daily debris
[Music]
you